اسمحوا لي أن أنقل التروس إلى
الموت المأساوي للممثل تشادويك بوزمان ،
نجم النمر الأسود الذي توفي بسرطان القولون
عن عمر يناهز 43 عامًا. هل
يجب أن تكون هذه دعوة للاستيقاظ للآخرين
حول أهمية الخضوع للفحص
بغض النظر عن العمر؟
اعلم أن التوصيات أه
الخاصة
بفحص سرطان القولون قد
تغيرت بالفعل منذ عدة سنوات
لفحص الجميع بدءًا من
سن 45 عامًا ،
رقم واحد ، رقم اثنين ، أنا
آسف
جدًا لفقدان مثل هذا الممثل المذهل
مثل هذا الممثل الموهوب
الذي  لقد كان مليئًا حقًا في حياته القصيرة
من العمر ومجموعة من الأعمال
التي لا تصدق ،
فنحن لا نعرف تفاصيل
تاريخ عائلته
ما هي عوامل الخطر التي قد تكون لديه على
الرغم من
أنه في واشنطن لدينا رقم
واحد في
وفاة الفرد بالسرطان  في البلاد وهناك
عدد لا يحصى من الأسباب التي تؤدي إلى وجود
تفاوت كبير بين
مجتمعات الأمريكيين الأفارقة واللاتينيين
مقابل
المجتمعات البيضاء.
أنت تشرب الهواء الذي
تتنفسه من الطعام الذي تأكله ولكن
بالتأكيد تحري عن
سرطان الثدي وسرطان القولون وسرطان البروستاتا
وسرطان الرئة وهما من
الأسباب الرئيسية للوفاة
لدى الرجال والنساء من الواضح أن الثدي
والبروستاتا على التوالي للنساء والرجال
وكذلك اللون البني الأسود  المجتمعات البيضاء ،
لذلك
أعتقد أن هذا يشير أيضًا إلى
أنه
كان هناك انخفاض حاد في
تشخيصات السرطان في
الأشهر الستة الماضية ويمكنني أن أخبرك أن
هذا أمر مقلق للغاية لأن
ذلك لن يؤدي
إلا إلى ظهور الأشخاص في وقت
متأخر.  تشخيص
العلاجات المتأخرة والنتائج الأسوأ للأسف ،
هناك الكثير لنتعلمه ولكن يمكننا البدء في
تنفيذ ما نعرفه الآن وهو أن
الفحص يحدث
فرقًا وحتى في فحص سرطان القولون
يمكن أن يحدث
نعم في تنظير القولون وبالتأكيد
يجب أن يحصلوا على المجموعات المعرضة للخطر  تنظير القولون ولكن بالنسبة
للآخرين يمكنهم الحصول
على واقي كولا غير جراحي وأشياء أخرى
ولكني أريد فقط أن أطلب من الناس عدم
تجاهل ذلك
فحصهم وبالتأكيد إذا
كانوا يعانون من أعراض
الدم في البراز ، أو تغيير في عادات الأمعاء ،
فقدان الوزن ، يرجى التماس
العناية الطبية الآن ،
فهذه مسألة حياة أو موت